meal was good we came back and um i
worked today and now we're doing the pod
thanks for coming here guys all the way
to tulsa um you guys are leaving
tomorrow
um i'm gonna be here for another
seven days or something
um
you don't feel like a king here i was me
and george k what king no because me and
george cloud was in the bathroom having
diarrhea when we were talking outside
what am i not having diarrhea that's
true that's a better question
we were trying to convince bobby that he
should live in a place like this
like a small town where he's kind of
like the mayor of the town everyone
knows him but he does not deal with
hollywood [ __ ] but when he wants to
deal with that he just flies back to
hollywood would that ever be an option
for us
i went on redfin with george when we
were at uh chick-fil-a
and i was looking at some of the houses
first of all
the amount of money that we spent on our
house
in la would have bought us acres of land
oh man i mean i could have my ranch out
here um
yeah controversial statement but i might
like tulsa more than l.a
i love it here that's bold do you love
la
yeah you know i i love it here too and
that's but you know i can take it only
like maybe a week out of the year
like this
i like how i don't know it feels very
peaceful
um it it has a really cool arts district
like i don't feel like
i'm completely in the middle of nowhere
it has a very like cool like uh indie
kind of vibe to it
yeah i i
i i can't be in a state where
abortion is illegal oh yeah i'd be
[ __ ] wouldn't i yeah yeah so we would
have had two kids if we lived here back
in the day
number two i just find that to be i
don't know
and then
and also though let me just say
something about the white people they're
really nice
the white people here are really nice
but
what's the
no there's no butt they're really nice
and
hey man
and there are some white people that you
can tell
they look
past you
okay like i'm um
i'm telling you this is not out of my
own imagination imagination i think
gilbert just felt it yeah
at the airport at the airport right it's
almost as if like
if you're walking down a hallway
and there's some white people god bless
them
are walking towards you and somebody has
to move out of the way
it's either they're going to be a
collision or i have to move
you don't mean they're not moving that's
the only option
yeah i mean they're not gonna move
they're they're not gonna go
excuse me and and move off to the side
right um like they had some sort of
wedding banquet or something here with
the real estate convention
you could see like i you know white
dudes in a suit not it's like a tuxedo
but they were they're cowboy hats
and then they're with their you know an
older white dude but then you know a
blonde younger wife and they're wearing
a gown
they they don't look at you
they don't smile they just
walk past you you know babe when you
look at me you don't see me as like your
young hussy
am i past that
you're like milf
you're not real
this is where i always feel
this is where i always feel like i
[ __ ] up why because i'm like okay like
i like the idea when someone's older
than me then i can always be like the
younger wife but with you it's like you
age backwards so it's i kind of [ __ ]
myself no no